il ya une chose que je ne comprends pas
autant en bois de mars comme nous avons
été surpris par une nouvelle maladie
vous pouvez comprendre que nous n'étions
pas suffisamment préparés quoique mais
ça c'est incompréhensible huit mois plus
tard
huit mois plus tard on se retrouve dans
une situation de pénurie d'un autre type
mais d'une pénurie aussi l type de
pénurie baal typiquement les lits de
réanimation au mois de mars
regardez ainsi qu'à un chiffre à
connaître au mois de mars 5000 lits de
réanimation en france au mois d'octobre
5000 lits dredd mathieu le déconfinement
a été raté nous n'avons pas été préparés
peut-être y at-il eu à paris qu'il n'y
aurait pas de remontée de l'épidémie je
pense que c'est ça qui s'est passé dans
la tête de jean de ceux qui nous
gouvernent qui se sont dit au fond ça va
passer comme ça et c'est vrai que
l'économie a tellement souffert dans
cette affaire qu'on voulait y croire
le problème c'est que quand vous
gouvernez vous ne pouvez pas faire des
paris oui on n'est pas prêt à regarder
les tests essayez de vous faire tester
pour sa rapide vous allez me convient
d'engager un jeune tu as appelé et
quelques jours me disant je suis positif
ah bon tu as fait le test il ya combien
de temps il ya quinze jours j'ai dit à
mathieu gallet président de la
république avait annoncé dans une
conférence nous étions la vrine qu'il
allait commander dix mille respirateur
en fait ils ont été commandés mais il a
été expliqué à l'assemblée nationale par
la directrice de l'offre de soins en
avril ou mai que les 10000 n'était pas
dix mille c'était en réalité 1600
respirateurs pour faire de la
réanimation les autres et qui existe sur
des respirateurs de transport donc nous
n'avons pas eu dix mille respirateur de
réanimation je suis inquiet parce qu'en
fait voyez vous il faut comprendre une
chose très simple c'est que tous les
efforts qu'on demande aux français
eh bien ils sont d'autant plus
importants que l'hôpital n'arrive pas à
soigner les gens et je pense qu'il faut
se poser une question
la seule on peut pas simplement demander
aux français de porter le poids de notre
absence de réflexion stratégique c'est
ça le sujet c'est à dire quand on dit
aux français il faut être responsable
civique citoyens porter votre masse
faire les gestes barrière ouais c'est
bien c'est bien sauf qu'en face il faut
aussi une stratégie nationale sur les
thèses sur les vaccinations sur les
respirateurs sur les réanimations sur
comment on fait pour aller récupérer
tous ces patients qui n'ont pas été
diagnostiqués au bas de mars avril mai
qui sont dans la nature qui voient leur
maladie évolue et qu'on sait pas traiter
il n'y a toujours pas de stratégie vous
il ya jusqu'à dire que ce gouvernement
navigue au fil de l'eau alors très
clairement je sais pas prêt personnel je
pense que vers ans le premier ministre
sont des gens qui ont de la bonne
volonté et qui travaille sauf qu'ils
sont débordés et c'est vrai aujourd'hui
on a l'impression que la seule stratégie
nationale de nos gouvernants c'est de
faire porter l'effort sur les français
et sur l'économie